amounts to the deadly staff in the city
of Las Vegas increased the number of
City Marshals patrolling the Fremont
Street area there's also been an
increased police presence on the Las
Vegas Strip that's right well that is
where Mary Jane beliesa joins us live
and Mary Jane you spoke to workers and
tourists what did they say about the
extra Patrol
student Christian here live
hunting and lost
who tell me they feel safe coming back
to work and visiting of course this is
right after that stabbing including one
local marketing and production company
tells me they started work again today
an increase in police presence seen on
The Strip today after Thursday's
stabbing which left two people dead
Rolando Espinoza is the director for
champagne Creative Group on Sunset and
Paradise the company hosts big events on
the Strip where they create cartoon
characters and contracts show Girls
Espinoza says for Live Events they've
had safety protocols and plagues for the
last several years ensuring their
clients to speak up if they see
something suspicious we work on the
strip with with festivals and special
events all the time so you're dealing
with the public you know 15 000 people
in some cases New Year's Eve on some
cases so you get to see it all and
you're always prepared for that but Las
Vegas is very safe I think the bottom
line is it's important to say that
message is that although there's a
random attack on the Strip it has
nothing to do with a day-to-day
visitations of Las Vegas Las Vegas is
safe Javonte from Arizona is here for
his 30th birthday he says while
Thursday's incident is terrifying to
hear he's always alert when walking the
streets I'm pretty so where am I around
it so I mean I mean where am I around it
so yeah
I don't feel sorry for the people that
got stabbed they're super random that
dude was crazy out his mind Rowan
Mustafa agrees he arrived at Thursday
night from Iraq we asked what's
happening and we heard that someone was
talking to some people and unfortunately
tour died as you said well uh this is
something weird but usually happens uh
we're okay we're safe here but I hope
this will never happen again
now tonight with the parade parade
downtown including all the other
festivities happening on the Strip
expect to see some extra patrols as well
in fact this morning me and my
photographer Mark we actually rode up
and down the strip where we saw a police
car every half mile reporting from the
strip Mary Jane vallenza 8 News Now